the 1960 Porsche 356 super was one of
the cars that launched the porsche
legend when was the true birthplace of
the Porsche brand where and how were the
first Porsches built we've set out in
search of answers traveling in
appropriate style and a classic Porsche
convertible the picture astound of
governed in Austria is home to a small
but exclusive Porsche Museum it was
founded by Helmut 5:05 as a boy he
witnessed the beginnings of the Porsche
brand and decided to devote his life to
it his first car was a Porsche 356 that
he bought in 1957 that first Porsche
became the first piece in his collection
five Wolfer bought up all the antiques
he could find that had anything to do
with Porsche
he opened his museum in 1982 the
collection is centered around the
original Porsche the 356 such as this
1952 coupe a version the bent window as
it's known to connoisseurs today this
rarity can't be had for less than
100,000 euros if at all
this white 356 convertible once owned by
a gamma nobleman has a special place in
five whole furs collection the little
town could be called the birthplace of
the Porsche brand it happened in a plain
little workshop by the maltitol Strawson
easy to overlook without the sign at the
end of World War two this hunt served as
Porsches first design department it's
hard to imagine that this early model
later produced in Stuttgart had its
humble origins here in Austria the model
that launched a cult that continues to
this day that became synonymous with the
high-end sports car even today it's 75
horsepower engine keeps it moving in
traffic with no problem
at first Porsche build its cars in
communes moving to Stuttgart in 1950 the
commune facility fell into disrepair 504
realized its historical value and saved
it from demolition in the 1980s he
recalls the operation was so primitive
that employees used to work in the open
doing repairs and things he enjoyed
watching them work on the various
prototypes such as the type 64 Berlin de
Rome racing model he found this was a
lot more interesting than going back to
work in the fields during the Second
World War Porsches design department
moved back to the moon to work in
relative peace ferdinand porsche senior
and junior worked on various projects
including engines complete automobiles
and even ski lift drives for the sake of
simplicity the projects were given
three-digit numbers after the war
Ferdinand Porsche senior was arrested
and accused of developing war materials
for the German Verma at the same time
the Porsche sports car brand was taking
off as Holmwood v over tells us
Ferdinand Porsche jr. used his time in
community to develop a car of his own it
was always on hand for the development
and test drives but he could never
really get out of his brilliant father's
shadow the first car to bear the Porsche
name was a little roadster with a design
number 356 seen here on an early test
drive together with an mg the comparison
gives some idea of how futuristic even
this first Porsche must have seemed this
first Porsche did not have its engine in
the rear as later models did but in the
middle right behind the driver Porsche
had invented the mid-engine sports car
for street driving
Ferdinand's senior was impressed the
company started mass-producing the car
using a number of parts from old VW's
and a military Depot Londo I'm at 5:04
list the front and rear axles engines
and transmissions even the 20th car
rolled out still had a steering wheel
from a VW kubu wagon the riveted rims
also came from the military vehicles
with these neuro 5 by 16 tires
those were the beginnings and 52 cars
were built by hand in Austria a unique
feature the Gaboon copays was the
hand-built aluminum body about 30 Coupe
A's and for convertibles are known to
exist today five Holford turned up his
specimen in the 1980s
he found the kamut kupe in a garden in
hind borg and bought it for 28,000
Austrian shillings only about 2,000 u.s.
dollars at the time at first he didn't
even know what he had today
it's invaluable though face 15 is coming
on it the portion name by itself has
helped to drive the prices to
astronomical Heights nowadays a 356 in
good condition commands six-figure sums
Porsche enthusiasts like 10 would 5
Wolfert certainly know what they have
now